boah ist das Licht Scheiße heute hi
Leute ein welcome aus America okay ich
muss vorsichtig sein ich habe nämlich
sehr lange schöne Fingernägel für
Amerika gemacht und wir stoßen an mit
Lacroix ich weiß nicht was Lacroix ist
ich weiß nur dass alle Amis die ich
immer geschaut habe früher also die
Youtuber immer Lacroix getrunken haben
und wahrscheinlich schmeckt es total
lecker
nö das
schmeckt halt wie Wasser mit Geschmack
also das ist doch langweilig allerdings
wieder eure Meinung willkommen zu einem
neuen Testvideo live aus Las Vegas wir
waren bei whole fruits
ist ein Supermarkt der viele organic
Sachen hat aber auch viele Sachen die
man sofort essen kann aus Deutschland
können wir das auch bei Rewe gibt's z.B
mittlerweile Sushi oder auch eine kleine
Salatbar aber dort ist es auf einem ganz
anderen Level und das essen was sie dort
verkaufen das testen wir heute Baba kann
es sein dass ich die Kamera hier
mitgenommen habe um eigentlich
Adventskalender Unboxings zu drehen ja
haben wir Adventskalender gefunden nein
die USA ist jetzt noch voll im Halloween
waren hier ist nichts an Weihnachten
keine Lebkuchen kein gar nichts wobei
ich auch nicht weiß wie viel Lebkuchen
und so sie sonst haben aber hier ist
auch wirklich nichts weihnachtliches
deswegen auch keine Adventskalender Mist
und deswegen testen wir heute essen
meine zweit Beschäftigung und jetzt
denkt bitte nicht dass hier einfach nur
langweilige so das kommen nein richtig
coole Lebensmittel wo man denkt wow das
gibt's in dem Supermarkt krass als
erstes habe ich diese green beans
mitgenommen und sie sind
getrocknet nein doch oh okay der Geruch
ist jetzt irgendwie nicht ganz so toll
wie es mir vorgestellt habe ich liebe
eigentlich grüne Bohnen essen ich finde
das ist immer so ein geiler Snack vom
Fernsehen es fühlt sich ein bisschen an
wie Pommes essen nur ohne Kalorien und
dann dachte ich ja das kann ja nur gut
sein
zehn von zehn wow super crunchy oh mein
Gott hätte ich das gerne für asmr
das ist einfach so eine Schock
getrocknete grüne Bohne
[Applaus]
nein nein
doch vielleicht ein bisschen
zwei von zehn was haben die gekostet
5 Dollar 50 ungefähr manchmal ach das
ist immer so kompliziert hier in den USA
weil die manchmal die Texas draufpacken
manchmal nicht und dann weiß man
eigentlich am Ende nie was man bezahlt
vor allem im Restaurant da gibt's ja
dann noch mal die Tipps also das
Trinkgeld oben drauf also es ist
wirklich sehr verwirrend hier okay aber
ich wollte nicht nur wissen wie
getrocknete grünen Bohnen schmecken
sondern auch der grüne Bohnensalat den
sie da verkaufen diese Portion kostet 4
$ 80 € 5 ein paar Grünen aber sind ja
nicht nur grüne Bohnen es sind ja
zubereitet der grüne Bohnen auch das
riecht besser und hier sind so Mandeln
drin und ein bisschen Öl und Pfeffer
Gewürze lucky schmeckie
also mir schmeckt die getrocknete
Variante besser aber der ist auch schon
echt lecker aber endlich essen wir mal
was Grünes wir haben die letzten Tage
immer noch irgendwelche Hash Browns
right Ex Pancakes frittiert und absolut
nicht grün jetzt komm irgendwas mal auf
5,99 das heißt oh jedes Ei ein Dollar
die verkaufende einfach halbierte Eier
und dann nimmt man das Eigelb raus
vermischt es ein bisschen Mayo und
Gewürzen spritzt es da wieder rein
bisschen Gewürz oben drauf und das ist
eigentlich eher so ein Party food also
das macht man so auf Partys mega ich
liebe Eier
sehr geschmacklos würde ich sagen
bisschen senfisch sieben von zehn aber
da also als ich die gesehen habe da war
ich da dachte halbe Eier okay anni
darüber willst du dich aber freuen
niedlich Meatballs seht ihr das das sind
riesengroße Melonen fette saftige Melone
Meatballs mit einer Tomatensoße drin wir
haben hier einmal die Tomatensoße ja
riecht wie schöne selbstgemachte
Tomatensoße und jetzt so ein meatball da
drin sind Bohnen Pilze
test test
[Musik]
als ob ein kerniges Brot Falafel und
Müsliriegeln Baby gemacht hätten so
schmeckt das sehr kernig und sehr gesund
nee meinst es nicht also die meetballs
bekommen von mir fünf von zehn nett
Gemeinde von zehn und wenn wir jetzt
schon mal beim Thema mietvoll sind wir
haben bei der warmen Theke meatles
Meatballs und äh wiegen Mac and cheese
mitgenommen also wirklich stellt euch
mal vor wir haben ein Supermarkt die uns
sowas holen können obwohl paar Edeka
Center werden langsam so dass man sich
da richtiges Essen holen kann
hmm manchmal mag ich den Cheddar
Geschmack im vegan wenn ich ein bisschen
zu doll aber das ist lecker manche ist
einfach so und sabschiges essen so und
jetzt haben wir hier noch mal einen
meatball in einer Barbecue Sauce
ja das ist lecker oh mein Gott ich kann
kaum glauben dass das vegan ist
mega gut 9 von 10 kommen wir mal weg oh
mein Gott ich bin schon sieben Tage
entlassen Vegas ich kann nur noch
Englisch sprechen das ist ein Cale Salat
ne ein rockhail salad von den Rock Hill
salad habe ich von Emma Chamberlain weil
sie geht in l.a immer zur whole Food ist
halt so ein Bioladen ne also da gehen
schon Leute rein die so ein bisschen
mehr Geld haben ich glaube für die
niedrigere Preisspanne hat man eher so
target und CBS aber für die Bussi Leute
gibt es kill salad der bestimmt richtig
gut schmeckt
extrem gesund ich glaube so viele
Vitamine hat mein Körper die letzte
Woche komplett insgesamt gehabt wie
diesen ein bisschen
weil ich finde das gar nicht schlecht
schmeckt nur sehr sehr grün also
goodbye Junk Food scale eigentlich ich
muss das einmal googeln Grünkohl kann
ich den jetzt zu Hause auch machen
ich kenne nur Grünkohl mit Kassler gute
Auswahl bis jetzt gut Auswahl der
bekommt von mir eine 9,5 nein das ist zu
viel so gut schmeckt er nicht ach von
zehn falls jetzt denkt vanessa ist jetzt
hier ein asmr Salat war food Test Video
vielleicht sie hatten auch Sushi da aber
ich war nicht in der Mut mir schon
wieder rohen Fisch reinzuballern
deswegen dachte ich probieren wir mal
diese Salat sushirollen Garten wettable
salad Road für okay für 9 $50 950 sind
also eigentlich kann man Dollar und Euro
mittlerweile gleich umrechnen da sitzt
nicht großer Unterschied also einfach
9,50 € tolle Präsentation sieht
natürlich schick aus wir haben hier eine
Rolle eine reispapierrolle mit Salat
drumherum und noch mal Gemüse gefüllt
okay man kann ja leider sagen in den USA
ist alles was Grünes ganz schön teuer
wir haben letztens ein Apfel gekauft
2,50 €. ein Apfel und eine Banane für 18
Cent das haben wir nicht ganz verstanden
zu den tippen wir das da rein
[Musik]
mega lecker wir haben da Avocado Gurke
mega einfach zu Hause machen boah das
muss ich mir merken das ist richtig
lecker und vor allem richtig knackig und
gesund
ja ich weiß es ist viel Plastik und ich
finde das auch einfach also ja Plastik
ist Plastik aber wie cool ist denn bitte
diese Lunchbox das erinnert mich an
diese lunschebilds die man früher noch
in Deutschland kaufen konnte man kann
sie tatsächlich noch in den USA kaufen
ich glaube die waren aber nicht so
gesund boah wirklich feiern wenn ich das
so auf der Arbeit oder so dabei hätte
dann kannst du dir hier zu deinem
gefülltes weinblättchen nehmen was hat
denn das gekostet 6,99 €. ja es ist okay
nein okay für so ein Legging Snack guck
mal so
ich liebe diese und Weinblätter und die
Sonne voll dann kannst du hier so den
Gürkchen nehmen und dann gibst du das
auch rein
[Musik]
und dein Cracker
ich weiß ich hätte eigentlich über Essen
von so Taco Bell und so zeigen sollen
oder in und out Burger aber schmeckt
gerade alles so gesund und lecker
für mich ist wichtig gesundes Essen
frisches Essen was gesundes damit wir
hier wenigstens ein bisschen ein
bisschen sündigen können habe ich einen
Cupcake geholt beziehungsweise einen
Muffin leute das ist ein Veganer
Schokomuffin könnt ihr das glauben wow
also die bekommt von mir zehn von zehn
[Musik]
der ist so lecker und 299 hat der Muffin
gekostet finde ich okay für den
Geschmack Body der ist so gut ich bin
echt eine tolle vegane Auswahl und jetzt
kommt unser Finale oh ja voll oh toll
Halloween Kekse okay einmal gespannt
oder was haben die gekostet 279 das
Stück okay die haben genau also entweder
holt man sich das oder ein Muffin ich
hatte den Muffin genommen aber die Kekse
sind mir schon richtig lecker
schmeckt wie so ein britischer
Shortbread ich glaube so schmeckt der
auch den weiß ich jetzt nicht an stabile
sieben von zehn also als Fazit muss ich
sagen das Essen ist zwar sehr teuer in
diesem hohlfood Supermarkt aber es ist
halt die einzig gute Alternative für
veganes Essen wir haben ein Restaurant
gefunden wo es wirklich leckeres veganes
Essen gibt und ansonsten sind vegane
vegetarische Alternativen hier wirklich
sehr schwer zu finden es kann aber
natürlich auch noch dran liegen dass wir
hier in Las Vegas sind vielleicht legen
Sie hier weniger Wert darauf dafür gab
es dort eine extrem gute Auswahl und da
sind wir jetzt richtig happy dass wir
uns da jetzt durch schlemmen können und
ansonsten wie hat es mir hier gefallen
gut aber es ist ein bisschen viel von
allem ne ich meine Las Vegas das ist
eine Party Stadt das merkt man schon
hier ne hier fahren viele Leute sehr
große Autos hier fliegen irgendwie
gefühlt alle paar Sekunden Flugzeug ab
und es ist hier sehr viel los hat
trotzdem mega Spaß gemacht die die Tages
zu verbringen wir sehen uns jetzt das
nächste mal wieder bei einem
Adventskalender auspackt Video bis dann
es wird schon richtig dunkel hier so
Kinder gute Nacht ne es wird
es wird schon dunkel tschüssi ne tschüss
abschalten